Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Heute ist aber auch echt früh.
Heute ist richtig früh. Ich glaube, wir haben noch nie so früh gepodkatet.
Nee, haben wir nicht. Wir hatten noch nie so wenig Zeit vom Aufwachen bis zum Loslegen. Aber was geht man nicht alles so für Opfer ein? Letztes Mal saßen wir auf der Bühne sogar.
Letztes Mal saßen wir auf der Bühne und heute sitzen wir wieder, machen wir wieder hier Weltnetz.
Genau, Weltnetz.
Weltnetz vermitteltes Podcast.
Ja, und wir sind auch ausnahmsweise mal nicht in einem Studio, sondern wir machen das, wie sich das so gehört. Schön aus der Ferne.
Das meinte ich mit Weltnetz vermittelten.
Ja, dass es mal so früh ist, dass ich noch nicht mal deine Witze mitkriege. Oh man, na das kann ja was werden. Tja, was müssen wir denn alles nachholen? Wir haben uns ja letztes Mal nur über Netzneutralität unterhalten. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt mal hier ein bisschen die News abklappern.
Genau, wir klappern ein bisschen News ab, die erwähnenswert sind, aber nicht so viele Diskussionen hergeben. Deswegen wird das heute eine Meldungssendung, denke ich mal.
Okay, fangen wir an mit dem gescheiterten Projekten.
Ja, die Leistungsschutzrecht-Petition ist erwartungsgemäß gescheitert mit 21.366 Beteiligten. Und nachdem wir ja letzte Woche darüber berichtet hatten, dass die Debatte war, dass man die mitzeichnen soll, ob man die mitzeichnen soll oder nicht, obwohl sie scheiße ist vom Text her, wurden dann nach der gescheiterten Petition natürlich die Stimmen laut, dass nur weil sie gescheitert ist, sie trotzdem natürlich ein wichtiges Signal war. Und sogar dann auch eine sehr interessante Stimme von Jonathan Nebel, der sagte, dieser Petitionsding, das kannst du mal machen, aber man kann jetzt auch nicht jedes Mal wieder mit einer neuen Petition kommen.
Ja, es ist ein wenig ein stumpfes Schwert geworden. Und ich glaube, die allgemeine Begeisterung für diese klickbasierte Protestbewegung, die ist so ein bisschen dahin. Ich glaube, ich habe in einem Artikel gelesen, das ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes Statement, mit Zensursolar, da war das so der schnelle Kit. Da könnte man dann schnell feststellen, alles klar, alle anderen sind auch irgendwie total entsetzt. Und die generelle Demonisierung des Netzes, die damals stattfand, die war einfach greifbarer. Das war dann sozusagen der Netzkonsens, wir drücken das jetzt darin aus. Und auch wenn ich jetzt nicht den Eindruck habe, dass dieses Leistungsschutzrecht irgendwie deutlich mehr Freunde hat, ist einfach das Vehikel-Petition an der Stelle auch einfach abgenutzt. Das reicht irgendwie nicht aus. Und in gewisser Hinsicht muss man sich auch darüber Gedanken machen, was denn dann eigentlich ausreicht, also was sind denn so adäquate, digital abbildbare Formen, in der so etwas dann vielleicht auch wirklich zum Ausdruck gebracht werden kann. Da habe ich auch keine gute Antwort. Liquid Feedback ist es an der Stelle sicherlich nicht, das ist dann einfach zu komplex. Aber nur so dieses MeToo-Ding funktioniert dann irgendwie nicht.
Das könnte eine Partei gründen.
Das ist aber jetzt mal eine echt gewagte These. Naja, aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Petitionen, die ein bisschen besser funktioniert haben, zum Beispiel zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ja, Kai-Uwe Steffens vom AK Vorrat hatte im März 2011, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, eine Petition gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingereicht und hatte damit 60.000 Zeichner erreicht. Wir erinnern uns irgendwie, ab 50.000 in einem bestimmten Zeitraum gewinnt man eine Anhörung vor dem Petitionsausschuss.
Und auch übrigens nicht mehr. Das ist sozusagen eigentlich schon das Maximum, was man da erzielen kann. Man wird dann gehört.
Genau. Das schrieb ja auch John F. Nebel sehr schön. Das ist ungefähr der unwichtigste Ausschuss, den der Bundestag zu bieten hat. Und außerdem ist er natürlich auch nach dem Proporz besetzt. Also da hat auch schwarz-gelb die Mehrheit entsprechend. Wird dieser Ausschuss dir dann auch gegenübertreten, wenn du ihm denn dann begegnest? Aber Kai-Uwe Steffens hatte am 15.10. dann seine Anhörung. Und der hat nochmal einen wichtigen Punkt dort zur Sprache gebracht. Und zwar verlangt er, dass die, also es gibt ja im Moment zwei Verfahren. Es gibt einmal das Strafverfahren gegen die EU wegen der, wegen dem Nicht-Umsetzen der Richtlinie. Das Strafverfahren von der EU gegen Deutschland wegen nicht-umsetzender Richtlinie. Und es gibt weiterhin die Prüfung der Richtlinie vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof. Die beiden Verfahren sind anhängig. Und jetzt sagt der Kai-Uwe, naja, erstens mal dieses Strafverfahren kann man eigentlich mal wegen nicht-umsetzen, kann man eigentlich mal hinten anstellen, hinter der Prüfung durch den Europäischen Gerichtshof, weil vielleicht sagt er, die Richtlinie ist nicht in Ordnung. Und warnt davor, dass selbst wenn der EGH jetzt sagt, diese Vorratsdatenspeicherungsrichtlinie ist nicht okay, die muss die EU umschreiben, streichen oder sonst was, dann berührt das nicht das Länderrecht. Das heißt, das Recht der Länder in der EU, das Mitgliedstaatenrecht. Das heißt, die, die dann eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben, die sich vielleicht sogar wie Österreich wegen der EU-Richtlinie eingeführt haben oder sich sogar da haben reinklagen lassen, die würden dann trotzdem diese lokale Gesetzgebung beibehalten und hätten ihre Vorratsdatenspeicherung, unabhängig davon, was der Europäische Gerichtshof über diese Richtlinie urteilt. Und das natürlich schon ein sehr gewichtiges Argument gegen dieses Theater, oh, wir kriegen aber hier Strafzahlungen und werden verklagt und wir müssen das jetzt unbedingt umsetzen.
Also die Anhörung hat stattgefunden. Hast du die irgendwie mitbekommen? Hast du da Aufzeichnungen gesehen?
Ich hab die Aufzeichnungen, ich hab mit den Anfangen kurz angeschaut, ich hab sie aber ehrlich gesagt nicht zu Ende geschaut. Also was man darin hat, ist wirklich eine sehr schöne Sammlung der Dinge, die gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung sprechen. Unter anderem bezieht er sich auf eine schöne Umfrage der Unionsfraktion, selbst der Unionsfraktion, die haben diese Umfrage gemacht, wo irgendwie auch zwei Drittel der Befragten gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung sind. Das heißt, ich meine selbst in ihr, es wäre gute Unionspolitik, das einfach mal sein zu lassen, sich weiter für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung einzusetzen. Den Audiomitschnitt der Veranstaltung haben wir aber natürlich in den Show Notes. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mal ein Crashkurs wäre, der vernünftig der ausgeglichenen Argumentation gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung hören möchte, dem sei das auf jeden Fall ans Herz gelegt.
Ich bin ja gerade in Österreich, hier im schönen Graz, und da hat sich auch was getan.
Ja, da gab es auch wieder was zum Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und zwar diskutieren die jetzt gerade in Österreich eine Urheberrechtsnovelle, die dort 2013 bevorsteht und die das Bundesjustizministerium Österreichs da gerade ausgestaltet. Und was sie gerne hätten, ist eine Pauschalabgabe auf Festplatten. Ich las das gestern, wurde getwittert von Anonymous Österreich. Anonymous Austria, dass sich unter den Kämpfern für eine Festplatten-Abgabe eine bekannte Bildhauerin befindet, die ihr Schaffen gefährdet sieht durch die Existenz von Festplatten. Es wurde ja auch gerade das Digital Rights Management für 3D-Drucker patentiert. Insofern muss die sich vielleicht echt Gedanken machen. Und es gab eine Demo von ungefähr 150 Menschen, die forderten die Festplattenabgabe jetzt. Und das war irgendwie sehr interessant, weil nicht ganz klar ist, wie viel von der Demo, von ein paar lustigen Spaßvögeln, sagen wir mal, gehyjagt wurde. Also ich meine, man kann sich schwer vorstellen, dass das jetzt alle ernst meint, die Leute, die da sind.
Na ja, hatten wir nicht schon vor einigen Monaten, zu Beginn unserer Serie, mal diesen Fall, dass so eine Urheberrechtskampagne von Künstlern in Österreich weitgehend als bezahlend und unterwandert galt?
Ja, das hat uns Thomas von erzählt.
Genau, was ist der Geier, also vielleicht kriegen die auch noch 150 Leute auf die Straße.
Na ja, ich glaube, hier sind eher, also bei den Gutenberg-Demos, es gab ja die Pro-Gutenberg-Demos in Berlin und Hamburg, wir erinnern uns als, als entsprechende Schilder auf dieser Festplattendemo. Also bei der Gutenberg-Demo in Berlin trafen sich ja die Monarcho-Hedonistische Front und die Copy-Paste-Kommunisten. Und was mich ein bisschen wundert, ist, dass sich unter den Schildern bei dieser Festplattenabgabedemo für die Festplattenabgabe ein großes Schild befindet, Kampf dem Copy-Paste-Kommunismus und ein Schild, was auf dem steht, Kultur muss ein knappes Gut bleiben und es kann eigentlich nicht sein, dass sie das ganz nein machen. Oder Raubkopierer-Hassen-Musik, Plan-Quadrat fürs Internet. Also da waren auf jeden Fall einige dabei.
Plan-Quadrat fürs Internet, sehr schön.
Aber bei den Demonstrationen pro Guttenberg war das ja auch bei der Grenze auch fließend zwischen denjenigen, die das sehr ironisch gemacht haben und denjenigen, die das mit religiösem Eifer dort betrieben haben. Insofern, die Bilder sind verlinkt, kann man sich anschauen. Es gibt aber nämlich noch mehr, was das Bundesjustizministerium Österreichs vorsieht für seine Bürger, nämlich das Leistungsschutzrecht nach deutschem Vorbild. Die sehen diese Debatte in Deutschland und sagen, hey, sowas wollen wir auch haben. Und April 2012 hat man in Österreicher die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt und jetzt wird im Standard zitiert, dass man sich das von Seiten des Bundesjustizministeriums anschaut, inwiefern denn die Vorratsdaten nicht vielleicht für Verletzung von Urheberrechtsverletz, für die Verfolgung der Verletzung von Urheberrechten, brauchbar wären.
Also sozusagen ein klassisches Gegenargument der Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgegner, dass mitnichten eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung nur für die Verfolgung schwerster Straftaten verwendet werden würde, sondern dass es durchaus auch mal drohte, dass die urheberrechtsorientierte Industrie da auf die tolle Idee kommt, wenn man ohnehin schon alles mitspeichert, dann könnte man doch da auch gleich mal nachschauen. Das ist hier quasi direkt im Entwurf.
Ja, also das ist, glaube ich, ein Staatssekretär, der da zitiert wird und der sagt, derzeit würde der Österreichische Gerichtshof für die Herausgabe der Logfiles von Nutzern dann eine ausdrückliche gesetzliche Ermächtigung verlangen, die es aber nicht gibt. Und das sei leider verständlicherweise nicht auf große Sympathien der Rechteinhaber gestoßen. Ach nee. Und die Möglichkeit, das zu sanieren, sieht er darin, dass man diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit einer gesetzlichen Vorabprüfung des Auskunftsersuchens irgendwie verbindet. Und die wesentliche politische Frage sei aber, ob man hier die Vorratsdaten verwenden kann. Und nach seiner Ansicht wird das ohne wohl nicht viel bringen, ja, das stimmt. Also der hat ja mit allem Recht, was er sagt, und er möchte also jetzt, er hat also sich jetzt ernsthaft wenige Monate, nachdem die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ins eigene Land geklagt wurde, sagt das BMJ jetzt, ja, dann wollen wir die natürlich auch für die Urheberrechtsverwerter verwenden, diese Daten. Für sonst was kann man sie ja auch kaum verwenden, weil ich meine, Terrorismus und so, da bleibt ja die Datenbasis gering, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung da irgendeine nennenswerte Möglichkeit wäre, dem eben beizukommen.
Ach ja, es ist immer wieder und täglich grüßt das Murmeltier, ne?
Österreich sollte damit, glaube ich, echt einen den Preis bekommen für das Land, was am schnellsten nach der Einführung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung diese ausfalten wollte, auf Delikte nach BGB, wahrscheinlich ist das Strafgesetzbuch, aber wirklich auf so Kleinstdelikte. Interessant ist, ich hatte ja gesagt, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich nach Österreich reingeklagt wurde. Die EU-Kommission hatte Österreich 2009 wegen Nichteinhaltung der Richtlinie angeklagt. Thomas hatte das ja auch im Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtet. Und der Patrick Breyer, der Fraktionsvorsitzende Piratenpartei Niedersachsen neuerdings und seit längeren Jahren aktiv im AK-Vorrat ist, hatte die Unterlagen zu dieser Klage verlangt, bei der Österreich letztendlich unterlegen war. Und weder Österreich noch die EU gaben sie ihm. Also hat er 2012 vom EUGH geklagt und seine Klageschrift veröffentlicht. Und die EU antwortete ihm dann irgendwie achzehnseitig auf seine Klageschrift, warum er diese Dokumente will, und dann antwortete die EU nein, gibt es diese und deshalb nicht. Und Patrick Breyer geht natürlich hin und veröffentlicht das auch auf seinem Blog. Er hat ja die Klageschrift auch veröffentlicht. Also veröffentlicht er auch die Erwiderung. Und er bekam dann von der EU-Kommission eine Klageandrohung. Und wurde ihm also gesagt, ja, in Anbetracht des Vorangegangenen fordert die Kommission ihren Mandanten, also ging natürlich an seinen Anwalt förmlich dazu auf, dafür Sorge zu tragen, dass die Klage sowie die Klagebeantwortung der Kommission von der oben genannten Internetseite und jeder anderen Internetseite, auf der sich diese Dokumente gegebenenfalls befinden, umgehend entfernt werden und auch ansonsten nicht der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht werden. Dieses Entfernen hat umgehend zu erfolgen, spätestens innerhalb von drei Tagen nach dem Erhalt des Briefes. Interessant ist, sie beziehen sich auf jeden Fall ein 14 Jahre altes Gerichtsurteil mit der Begründung ihres Verlangens, in dem irgendwie gesagt wird, daher darf eine Partei, die Zugang zu den Verfahrensstücken der anderen Parteien hat, Parteien sind hier nicht politische, sondern die Parteien vor Gericht, von diesen Stücken nur für die Verwendung ihrer eigenen Interessen und zu keinem anderen Zweck, wie etwa dem Gebrauch machen, die Öffentlichkeit zur Kritik am Vorbringen der anderen Verfahrensbeteiligten zu bewegen. Naja, ziemlich genau das hat Patrick Breyer natürlich gemacht, indem er diese Dokumente online gestellt hat, auf seinem Privatblog, was, sag ich mal, eine moderate Menge an Lesern hat. Dadurch, dass er jetzt natürlich diese Klageandrohung bekommen hat, ist das ganze überall großes Thema. Auch in netzpolitik.org hat die Dokumente mal zur Sicherheit auch bei sich auf den Server gelegt, wobei auch relativ klar ist, dass Patrick Breyer dieser Aufforderung nicht nachkommt, sondern natürlich diese Aufforderung auch online gestellt hat. Also man merkt, da gibt es irgendwie ein System. Tja, dann sind wir mal gespannt, was daraus wird, ob sie sich jetzt echt noch die Belöße geben, den AK-Vorrat oder einen Aktivisten des AK-Vorrats tatsächlich zu verklagen.
Es ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass die da so dünnhäutig sind. Also das ist ihnen jetzt wirklich da im Detail um dieses, oh jetzt habt ihr das veröffentlicht, man ist natürlich dieser klassische Streisand-Effekt, in dem Moment, wo sie sich natürlich so gerieren, richten sie die Aufmerksamkeit erst wirklich da drauf. Da fragt man sich, warum ihnen das eigentlich so wichtig ist.
Ja, also das ist ja auch wirklich das Spannende daran. Also man weiß es ja nicht, also das eigentliche, was ihnen wichtig zu sein scheint, ist ja, dem Patrick Breyer nicht die Dokumente zu geben, die die Österreich-Klage da betreffen. Dafür leisten sie sich ja den ganzen Aufriss. Andererseits weiß ich auch wirklich nicht, wie so Sachen zustande kommen, wie die EU-Kommission klagt oder die EU-Kommission erwidert etwas nicht und lässt sich verklagen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob so etwas nicht auch wirklich bei denen Tagesordnungspunkt ist oder ob da einfach der Praktikant einmal die Woche mit dem Anwalt telefoniert und sagt übrigens, das, das, das und das hätten wir gerne weg. Das weiß ich nicht.
Na ja, vielleicht ist es auch einfach, dass da irgendjemand die Wahrheit erzählt und das muss unbedingt verhindert werden. Kann Spuren von Wahrheit enthalten?
Denkbar ist es. Was sicherlich Spuren von Wahrheit enthalten hat, war ja das Gutachten zur Abgeordnetenkorruption, das vor einigen Wochen bei netzpolitik.org veröffentlicht wurde. Das hatten sie sich geholt. Ich glaube, André, war das über eine Informationsfreiheitsgesetz-Anfrage. Es war ein Gutachten, das durchgeführt wurde vom wissenschaftlichen Dienst des Bundestages. Und die haben gesagt, sind zu dem Ergebnis gekommen, dass in Deutschland ist eigentlich die schwächste, oder eine vergleichsweise sehr schwache Grundlage, gesetzliche Grundlage gegen Abgeordnetenkorruption gibt. Und dieses Gutachten bekam netzpolitik.org bzw. André mit der Auflage, es nicht zu veröffentlichen. Und wie gesagt, man erkennt dann ein System. Es landete auf netzpolitik.org mit dem Hinweis, dass man gebeten wurde, es nicht zu veröffentlichen ist, aber irgendwie nicht einsieht. Und dann gab es natürlich ein Schreiben des Bundestages an Markus Becke dal, per Einschreiben rückschein vom Deutschen Bundestag von Professor Schöller. Ich weiß nicht genau, welches Amt er da bekleidet. Er ist der Leiter der Abteilung Wissenschaft und Außenbeziehungen und arbeitet wohl für den Ministerialrat Klaus Aschinger. Und sagt, ja, hier am 1.10. wurde auf der Internetpräsenz netzpolitik.org das Gutachten Rechtsfragen im Kontext der Abgeordnetenkorruption des Wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages veröffentlicht. Ohne dass meine Zustimmung hierzu vorlage, ich bitte Sie daher, die fortwährende rechtswidrige Veröffentlichung unverzüglich spätestens jedoch bis zum 17.10., das war gestern, einzustellen und die Veröffentlichung zukünftig zu unterlassen. Mit freundlichen Grüßen. Ja, man kann sich ungefähr vorstellen, wie Markus Becke da auf so einem Brief reagiert. Er stellt ihn natürlich öffentlich und sagt, nee.
Ja, vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr Streisand in die Augen gestreut.
Auch so was von krass, oder? Gutachten zur Abgeordnetenkorruption und du sagst so, ey, ich will auch ein Eis psch, nichts erzählen.
Diese Korruptionsgeschichte, die ist ja auch wirklich hanebüchen, wer das noch nicht so verfolgt hat. Deutschland ist so eines der letzten Länder auf diesem Planeten, die da entsprechende UN-Richtlinien noch nicht umgesetzt haben und sich einfach standhaft im Bundestag weigern, da endlich mal ein klares Votum für ein Gesetz zu entwickeln, in dem einfach mal klar gesagt wird, dass Abgeordnete nicht bestechlich zu sein haben und es kommt einfach seit Ewigkeiten nicht zustande.
Spannend vor dem Hintergrund finde ich, dass wir gerade hier in den Medien, der per Steinbrück seine Reihe an Arsch tritt, kriegt wegen Nebeneinkünften, weil er der Bundestagsabgeordnete ist, mit den höchsten Nebeneinkünften oder mit den meisten. Mit den höchsten weiß man ja gar nicht, weil das ja sinnigerweise bei siebentausend, also es gibt irgendwie drei Kategorien, irgendwie bis 3000, unter 7000 und über 7000 Euro im Jahr. Ich meine, eine nennenswerte Einkunft, die ich von jemandem beziehe, die ist sehr weit über 7000 Euro im Jahr. Das mag vielleicht für den einen oder anderen schwer vorstellbar sein, aber du landest natürlich sehr schnell in der 7000 Euro-Kategorie, wenn du ein Jahresgehalt irgendwo beziehst. Und das ist natürlich auch das Lustige an diesen Richtlinien, die sich da selber auffällig haben, dass es im Prinzip sofort mit jeder Einkunft über 7000 Euro ist. Interessanterweise ist der Pierre Steinbrück aber teilweise mit einzelnen Vorträgen über den 7000 Euro, was dann wiederum streckenweise für Überraschungen sorgt. Aber interessant finde ich, dass das Medial gerade der Steinbrück auf den Sack kriegt, wegen angegebenen Nebeneinkünften. Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass das in Ordnung ist. Gleichzeitig aber ihr Gutachten zu Abgeordneten Korruption. Da hält der Bundestag dann doch zusammen.
Ja, es ist wirklich ein merkwürdiges Gentleman's Agreement an der Stelle. Und es kommt einfach extrem fisch hier rüber. Und so etwas wie hier bei netzpolitik.org alles zu depublikieren, trägt jetzt nicht unbedingt dazu bei, dass man der Meinung ist, dass schon alles da der Richtigkeit hat.
Kommen wir zum letzten Thema, auch hier geht es um Geld.
Ja, unsere Boulevard-Abteilung.
Die Boulevard-Abteilung, extra ins Ende geschoben für diejenigen, die jetzt ausschalten wollen und für diejenigen, die die ganze Zeit darauf warten, dass wir endlich wieder über Julio Assange sprechen. Die offene Frage im Raume war ja, was ist eigentlich mit der Kaution, die die Bürgen bezahlt haben? Sie hatten ja 140.000 Pfund gebürgt dafür, dass Julio da bleibt im Rahmen seines Aufenthalts auf der Grafschaft mit der elektronischen Fußfessel. Wie wir alle wissen, hat er diese Grafschafter verlassen und somit gegen seine Bail-Auflagen verstoßen. Und jetzt müssen die Bürgen 93.500 britische Pfund, dieser insgesamt 140.000 Pfund, auch tatsächlich entrichten. Ungefähr 116.000 Euro, das Pfund steht gerade dem Euro gegenüber nicht so stark, wie es das einmal tat. Und zwar, weil sie Assange mit seiner Flucht in die äquadorianische Botschaft unterstützt hätten. Sie hätte es ihm zu leicht gemacht, sich der britischen Justiz zu entziehen. So viel dazu, die müssen jetzt zahlen. Julien Assange, noch unter seinem alten Namen veröffentlicht, Cypher Punks, Cypher Punks Bewegung ist so, wie bezeichnet man, was sind die Cypher Punks? Also eigentlich, das weißt du vielleicht besser als ich.
Ja, das ist ja auch so ein alter Begriff aus einem anderen Science-Fiction-Buch. Ich komme gerade ins Schwimmen, wer den Begriff geprägt hat, war es Gibson, ich glaube, und Juden Milhen steht in Wikipedia. Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist es ein Begriff, der so in den 70er- und 80er-Jahren dann aufgekommen ist und schnell große Beliebtheit gefunden hat, sozusagen für so eine neue Generation von Menschen, Hackern und so weiter, die halt einfach, also, Entschuldigung, ich bezogene mich auf Cyberpunk, du beziehst dich auf Cypher-Punks, die Cypher-Punks wiederum sind ein separates, das ist einfach noch zu früh heute Morgen, sozusagen noch mal so eine Bewegung von Leuten, die sich eben speziell der Kryptographie widmen und an der Stelle eben gehackt haben. Cypher-Punks sind auch alles extrem kundige Leute und es ist auch eine sehr weltweite, lose Community von Menschen. Cypher-Punks sind auch immer wieder sehr hilfreich, wenn man mal vor der Problematik steht, dass man irgendwo so einen WLAN benutzen möchte und es wird einem eine Registrierung vorgeschrieben, dass man sich das mal so registrieren sollte, damit man hier kostenlos was benutzen kann, dann sollte man zunächst einmal das Login Cypher-Punks mit dem Passwort Cypher-Punks probieren. Das funktioniert sehr häufig. Das ist echt wirklich erstaunlich. Und auf jeden Fall darauf nimmt er hier Bezug.
Da zählt er sich auch selber zu. Ich glaube, der Mythos um die Cypher-Punks ist ja diese Mailing-Liste, die ich gar nicht weiß, ob sie tatsächlich noch immer noch gibt. Es gibt noch cypherpunksatalkaida.net, aber ich glaube nicht, dass da noch so viel drauf los ist.
cypherpunks.org.
Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall diese Mailing-Liste, oder es gab sie mal, aber sie hat ihren hohen Höhepunkt überschritten, der Nutzung, und insgesamt sind sie stark auf Privatsphäre, Anonymität und Pseudonymität, versteift ein bisschen gegen Zensur und Überwachung und haben so häufig diese Ideen des doppelten Versteckens, was ja auch die großartige Idee von Julian Assange war, das versteckte zweite Volume in der encrypted Volume, dass man also quasi eine verschlüsselte Festplatte ist, im Prinzip ja komplett mit zufälligen Daten gefüllt. Und auch der Teil, auf dem nichts steht, ist mit zufälligen Daten gefüllt, damit der Angreifer keinen Rückschluss darauf hat, wie stark diese Festplatte gefüllt ist. Und die Idee von Rubber Hosted, einem Tool von Julian Assange, war, ich habe eine verschlüsselte Festplatte, Volume 1, und wenn ich das entschlüsselte, zeigen sich ein paar Dateien. Der Rest dieser Festplatte ist gefüllt mit zufälligen Daten. Und das ist auch zu erwarten bei einer verschlüsselten Festplatte. In diesem Teil verstecke ich aber eine zweite verschlüsselte Festplatte. Und die Existenz dieser Festplatte kann aufgrund der zufälligen Daten, die in diesem Restbereich stehen, nicht mehr nachgewiesen werden. Das heißt, wenn jemand mit einem Knüppel hinter mir steht und sagt, gib dein Passwort ein, was ja immer noch die größte Sorge ist von allen Leuten, die irgendwas mit einem Passwort sichern, dann kann ich in der zweiten Stufe plausibel behaupten, dass es keine mehr gibt.
Also man hat sozusagen die Möglichkeit, sich mit seinem richtigen Passwort einzuloggen und an seine Daten ranzukommen. Aber man hat auch die Möglichkeit, sich mit einem alternativen Passwort einzuloggen und dann kommt man auch an Daten, aber eben an Daten, die einfach, naja, gibt es dann irgendwie autoexit.bat und config.sys und das war es im Wesentlichen.
Genau und ein bisschen Porn. Du musst immer ein bisschen Porn da mit reintun. Entschuldigung, du musst immer ein bisschen Porn da mit reintun, weil sonst ist das unglaublich. Das war mal irgendwie so eine Feststellung in Großbritannien.
Ja, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Fällt mir jetzt gerade kein passender Dateiname dazu ein. Wie heißen die Dateien normalerweise? Du kennst dich doch da bestimmt besser aus als ich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich versuche die ganze Zeit, ein bisschen Porn zu bekommen, aber ich finde das nicht hier im Internet.
Conflict Doxys ist doch für den gemeinen Nerd schon Porn genug oder nicht?
Genau, also die Cypherpunks, viele große Figuren der Hacker-Geschichte gehen auf die Cypherpunks zurück. Julian Assange war auch ein Cypherpunk und hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben. Und in diesem Buch kommen wohl auch zu Wort, oder sind daran beteiligt, Jacob Eppelbaum, der Tor-Entwickler, Andy Müller-Magun, Chaos Computer Club-Mitglied, ehemaliger Vorsitzender, oder wie auch immer, was ist das? Vorstandsvorsitzender wahrscheinlich?
Ne, also Vorsitzender war er, kann ich mich gar nicht erinnern, ob er diese Rolle überhaupt jemals eingenommen hat. Andy war halt lange Jahre im Vorstand, ist dazu bei der letzten Mitgliederversammlung aber rausgeflogen. Mittlerweile ist er im Vorstand der Warholland-Stiftung. Wobei diese Vorstandstätigkeit, muss man echt nochmal betonen, jetzt beim CCC keine wirklich besonders exponierte Bedeutung hat. Aber Andy war halt jahrelang Sprecher für den Club und ist auch heute immer noch ein sehr bekanntes und sichtbares Mitglied.
Der ist dran beteiligt und Jeremy Zimmermann, L'Aquadateur du Net, ein kleiner, sehr findiger Hacker und Lobbyist für die Freiheit des Internets. Diese vier Personen, das werde ich jetzt gleich nochmal verlinken, da gibt es auch eine Gesprächsrunde, die auch, glaube ich, von Russia Today veröffentlicht wurde, die in England als Assange noch mit Fußfessel im Norden saß. Genau, das war ganz interessant eigentlich. Die verlinken wir mal. Genau, und dieses Buch wird jetzt veröffentlicht. Mir ist da bis jetzt noch nichts von Auszügen bekannt. Da muss man mal schauen, wie interessant das wird. Aber die eigentliche News, die wirkliche Boulevard-News ist ja, dass Wikileaks jetzt eine Paywall hat. Und das ist echt spannend. Man geht also auf wikileaks.org, und dann kommt da die Wikileaks-Seite. Und dann sagt man, naja, okay, ich bin jetzt hier mit einem normalen Browser, der alle Scripts zulässt. Ich habe bis jetzt noch nicht mehr angeschaut, wie ich das umgehe. Und dann sagt man, ach ja, hier Wikileaks. Gucken wir uns mal hier was an. Ein geleaktes Dokument möchte ich jetzt sehen, welches von Wikileaks der Freiheit des Netzes zugeführt wurde. Und dann finde ich hier gar keine Dateien, oder was? Zeige ich doch mal eine Datei. Ach so, hier nach Datum. Wenn ich da draufklicke, dann wird die Seite rot. Und ich sehe, mir wird nahegelegt, Dollar zu spenden an Wikileaks. Und Sie haben ja jetzt seit den USA, die der Präsidentschaftswahlkampf geführt wird, haben Sie ja so ein ganz komisches Video, indem Sie sagen, indem Sie den Obama mit seinen Versprechungen konfrontieren, was die Freiheit von Whistleblowern und die Medienfreiheit und die Meinungsfreiheit usw. betrifft und konfrontieren ihn mit diesen Aussagen. Und dass er sich da ja überall alles gar nicht dran gehalten hat. Und wollen deshalb, dass man bei dieser Wahl Wikileaks wählt. Es ist ziemlich unklar, was das soll. Also man kann 15, 25, 50 oder 100 Dollar spenden. Oder Other. Oder Other, ja, man kann auch mehr spenden. Und dieses Pop-Up geht dann auch irgendwann wieder weg. Aber die Tatsache, dass dieses Overlay darüber geschaltet wurde, hat Julian Assange und Wikileaks einer sehr harschen Kritik ausgesetzt, nämlich aus dem Umfeld von Anonymous.
Also kann man das überhaupt nicht umgehen hier? Also man kann hier nicht nein sagen oder was?
Es sieht im Moment echt nicht danach aus. Also ich hab, warte mal, ich hab hier mal, muss man mal ein NoScript einschalten hier in einem anderen Browser. Also es steht donate or spread this campaign to make the pop-up go away. Also das heißt, sobald du irgendwie jetzt hier mal auf Tweet drückst oder spendest oder das auf Facebook postest, dann geht dieses Ding weg. Und es kommt nur einmal pro Tag. Aber ich habe festgestellt, wenn du ein paar Mal auf Reload drückst, dann ist es auch irgendwann weg. Aber ich habe es noch nicht genau mir angeschaut, wie es funktioniert. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, wenn du JavaScript deaktivierst oder so, dann wird das schon klappen. Es ist schon ein bisschen peinlich, ne? Denn dieses Vote Wikileaks, dieses YouTube-Video ist jetzt auch nicht die beste Schaffung, die beste Kreation, die Wikileaks bisher hervorgebracht hat. Interessant ist, dadurch, dass sie das ja jetzt als dieses Video einmelden von YouTube auf ihre Wikileaks-Seite. Also sorry, ich meine, wie können die so bescheuert sein? Als wenn YouTube jetzt nicht sehen würde, woher die Zugriffe kommen. Also ich meine, sie haben jetzt ein Tracking-Video von YouTube in ihrer Seite. Gut, das hatten sie, glaube ich, mit Collateral-Mörder auch schon. Aber das haben sie jetzt auf jeder Seite. Das heißt, YouTube kriegt nach meiner Auffassung, oder es ist das YouTube-Video, ne? Also nach meinem Verständnis kriegt YouTube jetzt bei jedem Seitenaufruf von Wikileaks von jemandem auf jeden Fall dessen IP-Adresse. Und sie haben ein Tracking darüber, wie oft die Leute sich auch tatsächlich dieses Video angucken. Und die Zahl der Menschen, die das Video bis jetzt gesehen haben, ist immer noch verhältnismäßig gering. So, auf jeden Fall führte das dazu, dass Anonymous dann mit Julian Assange brach. Es gibt einen schönen Titel bei Heise Online, Anonymous bricht mit Julian Assange. Ja, gut, egal. Es geht ja darauf zurück, dass in der 2010 Anonymous im Rahmen der Operation Payback Wikileaks meinte, Schützenhilfe dadurch zu leisten, dass sie die Webseiten von Mastercard und Visa Card und so weiter dedossen, weil diese keine Payments für Wikileaks annehmen. Aber jetzt, diese tolle Gemeinschaft ist Aziz. Diese tolle Freundschaft hat jetzt ein Jesende gefunden. Für was auch immer das Wert ist, wer auch immer da gerade gesprochen hat. Assange verteidigte sich dann natürlich und sagte, ja, das kostet ja alles Geld.
Ihr seid ja alle unterwandert vom FBI.
Genau, ihr seid unterwandert vom FBI. Und deswegen, ja, also deswegen müsste man auch noch ein bisschen nicht hören.
Und schon weit vorangeschritten.
Schon alles sehr weit vorangeschritten, ja. Und die erklärt aber, dass die Spendenkampagne deshalb notwendig ist, weil sie ja so lange unter der Finanzblockade gelitten haben. Ja, also er hat ja immer vorgerechnet, wie viel Geld Wikileaks fehlt, weil man nicht über Visa spenden kann. Und was da natürlich ein bisschen vermischt wurde, ist vielleicht auch, dass Menschen dann irgendwann auch andere Gründe vielleicht hatten, weniger oder nicht mehr an Wikileaks zu spenden. Aber okay, Wikileaks möchte gerne Geld haben und hat sich dazu entschieden, eine Paywall zu machen. Und es gab mal wieder einen großen Aufschrei im Internet.
So, keinen Aufschrei im Internet gibt es, weil wir jetzt in der Lage waren, dann auch schnell eine neue Sendung nachzuschieben, wie wir es hier immer probieren, Linus.
Ja, und was mich jetzt ein bisschen traurig stimmt, ist, dass es müsste eigentlich einen Aufschrei geben, weil es war heute die Folge 42 und wir haben 042 Witz gemacht.
Ja, das stimmt, wir haben jetzt irgendwie keinerlei speziellen Nummer gemacht. Aber vielleicht machen wir ja nochmal so eine hübsche Sendung von der Bühne. Das war ja irgendwie dann doch ganz nett. Auch wenn wir uns jetzt nicht gerade unbedingt die spaßigsten Themen herausgesucht haben. Aber es ist ja auch immer nicht ganz so einfach in diesem Bereich.
Ja, also Sendung von der Bühne war glaube ich sehr gut. Hat mir sehr gut gefallen und vielen Dank nochmal, dass du mich da gerettet hast. Jetzt starten wir beide in den Tag.
Genau, jetzt geht es um die Wurst.
Ich darf mir gar nicht verraten, wie früh das hier ist.
Sehr früh. Linus, dann sagen wir Tschüss, wa?
Sagen wir Tschüss.